[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARA SOSS: Welcome to
our session covering
the professional Google
Workspace administrator
training and certification.
We have some great
opportunities to share
with you and your teams.
I'm Mara Soss, the Google Cloud
credentials engagement lead.
With the demand for Google
Workspace skills increasing,
our partners and
customers are looking
to grow their team
of professionals
with the validated
Google Workspace skills
to help them achieve their
digital transformation
and productivity goals.
Getting your team
certified can be
the first step in not only
improving client satisfaction,
yet are also a great way to
invest in skills development
for your teams.
Recently collected data
states that nearly 70%
of organizations recognize
that certification speed up
technology
implementation, leading
to greater staff productivity.
The same report also found
that 85% of IT consultants
agree that
certification represents
validation of expensive
product and process knowledge.
Finally, fully certified
teams are 35% more likely
than partially certified
teams to finish projects ahead
of schedule, typically
reaching their targets
more than two weeks early.
To talk more about the job
role of a Google Workspace
administrator and the impact
that the professional Google
Workspace administrator
certification can
have on your
business and career,
I welcome Kimberley, Google
Workspace customer engineer.
KIMBERLEY ATALA: Certified
Workspace administrators
have an important role
at any organization.
They enable people to work
together, communicate,
and access data in a secure
and efficient manner.
Operating with an engineering
and solutions mindset,
they use tools, programming
languages, and APIs
to automate workflows.
The Google Workspace
training and certification
offers to grow and showcase
your team's skills,
help them gain confidence
in their abilities,
and stay current to give their
company a competitive edge.
I've worked with businesses
evaluating and deploying
Google Workspace for
seven years at Google,
and as a customer engineer,
I've seen firsthand
how the certification helps
my customers achieve business
goals faster and solve their
organization's toughest
business challenges quicker with
a team that has the right Cloud
skills.
With my customers who have
gone through the training
and achieved the
certification, they
have seen accelerated deployment
timelines, hardened security,
and quicker resolution to IT
issues on an ongoing basis.
I worked with one customer
with several thousand users
facing a re-up on their
on-prem exchange server.
Their extremely lean IT team
didn't have the bandwidth
to manage everything,
and leadership
preferred not to expand hiring.
But they had been using their
current solution for decades.
To make matters
even more difficult,
their industry was facing
new compliance requirements
for handling sensitive
data, so they really
needed to reduce time spent
administering while avoiding
any gaps in security.
The Workspace training
and certification
helped their existing IT team
translate their experience
administering their
current systems
and learn Google best
practices-- not just
solving the same problems
with replacement features
but finding actual new
approaches to solve
those business challenges in a
more secure and automated way.
They were even able to
solve a few new business
challenges along the way
with their newfound skills
in deploying zero trust.
You're the expert on how your
organization operates today,
but the Google professional
Workspace administrator
certification can
build your team
of experts and unlock
Google technology
to propel your business forward.
MARA SOSS: Validate your team's
Google Workspace expertise
with the professional Google
Workspace administrator
certification.
Get your team started
today with 30 days
of free hands-on training
through our on-demand platform,
Google Cloud Skills Boost.
Best of luck in your training
and certification journey.